well for years liberal cities and states
have been claiming the right to ignore
federal immigration law
now one small-town police chief in
Washington state is saying the same
principle can be applied to far-reaching
gun laws a new gun control ordinance in
Washington imposes stricter background
checks raises the age for buying a
semi-automatic rifle and allows gun
owners to be criminally prosecuted if
their firearms are stolen and then used
illegally Lauren Culp is the police
chief of Republic Washington and says
that he wants his town to be a sanctuary
from these new gun laws some local
residents opposed the new measure in
Washington watch opponents say it forces
gun owners to secure them in a way that
could put them in danger I'm concerned
it's not being able to access my gun
when I need it you're not gonna tell the
criminal can you hold on a moment
because we have a law that I have to you
know safe safely is store it in the
garage somewhere and you know in the and
so can you hold on a moment I'm going to
go take it and I'll go into different
notes out there moved on you call the
police Oh or things go down it's less
than one minute so those seconds count
police chief Lauren Culp joins us
tonight by Skype chief thanks very much
for coming on it's good to see you
good evening Tucker thanks for having me
so is this in effect a sanctuary your
town or public Washington from the gun
laws of your state I have suggested an
ordinance and recommended it to the City
Council and they're in the process of
reviewing that and doing their due
diligence to see if they want to pass
that but as far as the police department
goes we will not be enforcing that so
cities that have decided to ignore
federal immigration law have received
the applause and support of almost
everyone on the American left what do
you think the response will be if your
town passes this ordinance I don't think
the same people would be very happy the
thing about it is illegal immigrants are
covered by the Bill of Rights in the
Constitution and gun owners are a very
good point
so what will happen next do you think
well the governor of the state try and
force you to enforce the law that you
think is a
constitutional well I don't know how he
could Tucker because we live in a
constitutional republic contrary to what
a lot of people tell us that we live in
a democracy but we have the rule of law
in this state and across the United
States and the Constitution is the law
of the land and everybody knows what the
Second Amendment says a lot of your
viewers might not know what the
Washington State Constitution says about
firearms but real quickly it says the
right of the individual citizen to bear
arms and defense of himself or the state
shall not be impaired so that's even
more explicit than the Second Amendment
so I don't know how they can get around
that and try to force me to go against
my oath of office to uphold that
interesting I had no idea your state's
constitution said that it's it sounds
like it's being already ignored it
throughout the state of Washington so
very quickly this state law would
require gun owners to keep their guns
locked up at all times it requires you
to keep it locked up because if someone
gains access to your gun say you're away
from home and someone breaks in your
home and steals your gun goes out and
commits a crime with it you can be
charged up to a felony for that person
getting your gun and committing a crime
with it if someone was ridiculous
if someone says you're charging someone
who has her car stolen and the person
drives off and goes through a crowd of
people huh it's ridiculous well that is
ridiculous
and good for you for fighting back
against it chief cop thank you very much
for coming on and explaining that a real
quick message for you though yes
ten-inch Amane nugent told me to tell
you hi always a welcome message
especially on a Friday thank you
thank you good to see you